we begin this morning with two large
out-of-control wildfires burning at
opposite ends of California leaving at
least nine people dead the campfire
north of Sacramento has destroyed more
than 6,700 structures and consumed more
than 90,000 acres most of one town was
incinerated the woolsey fire near Los
Angeles is smaller but threatens
hundreds of thousands of people as
flames surge toward the Pacific Ocean
Jamie yuccas is in Malibu California
this morning good morning Jamie good
morning let me show you the scene in
much of Malibu right now flames are
racing down hillsides toward the Pacific
Ocean this fire is now 35,000 acres or
54 square miles that's roughly the size
of Akron Ohio overnight the woolsey
fires showed no signs of slowing down as
homes reduced to their foundations by
the flames toppled to the ground so many
homes have burned in Southern California
200,000 people have been evacuated
that's roughly the population of salt
lake city bone dry conditions and
unrelenting winds have blown this blaze
forward and a breakneck pace
firefighters are struggling to keep up
people on the ground in this Malibu
neighborhood watched yesterday as planes
dumped fire retardant to delay the
flames steady march toward the Pacific
Ocean we spoke with one man as he walked
to the ash and remains of the home he
fled memories gone I mean it was all
perfect condition two and a half hours
ago when I was standing there as
thousands of evacuees scrambled to leave
their endangered neighborhoods
bumper-to-bumper traffic piled up on
California's Pacific Coast Highway where
just hours ago the fire jumped the road
nearby a student journalist at
Pepperdine University took video as
flames crested the hills above campus
and in a late-night meeting with some of
the school's more than 3,500 students
President Andrew Benton urged them to
stay put we keep you safe
all the resources that we had with food
water with buildings that are built to
withstand challenges like this
up north in Paradise California it looks
like a war zone the town of 27,000
people was completely destroyed by the
so called camp fire firefighters are
just beginning the process of containing
that blaze at least nine people died in
the flames some in their cars as they
tried to escape and dozens more are
missing officials are now investigating
two deaths inside the fire line like
this one more than a hundred buildings
have burned to the ground but the Los
Angeles County Fire Chief says that
number could go up once they can assess
more in the daylight most haunting
images Jamie yuccas in Malibu California
Thank You Jamie